my real fear is that they're gonna
invent a better eye for blind people and
when they do they look how amazing this
is
we've given blind people the ability to
see again optimism but now they also
have all these other features that you
don't have with your regular eyes let us
scoop those bad boys out and put some
[ __ ] gay robot eyes binocular eyes
I'm a little worried about that yeah
realistically worried about that it came
it came from we were watching this video
once where there was a guy who got his
arm and his leg bit off by sharks we got
a attacked by a shark when he's surfing
so yeah this carbon-fiber hand that
totally articulates like a real hand and
he's standing there with his from his
knee down was an artificial leg and he
was walking around and moving like a
regular person I was like look at this
guy this is incredible I'm like he's
kind of a bionic guy yes his hand was
moving around he could shake your hand
and he seems so normal I'm like what if
it gets like many many generations
better than this where it has like Luke
Skywalker when he goes hand chopped off
by Darth Vader remember we got that
robot hand and there's people working on
this every day so I kind of figure we're
headed in that direction we're like
what's this Jamie side just googled
something it's not out yet this is
called a macula which is a AR lens that
you wear with sunglasses so in together
they make an AR situation a lens as a
contact and then sunglass yes very the
picture that they yeah what is it macula
oh you can have a lens here and you
haces go over top
what about creepy dude it's not out yet
it's just this you can invest in it so
it's more it's like how magic leap was
about a year year and a half ago like
I'm not invested in anything that uses
this guys their cover boy what's up face
man that's a [ __ ] robot man he's an
alien he looks like the guy from men in
black remember when the alien put the
skin on remember that's what he looks
like here something wrong with the left
side of his face man he's wearing
someone's skin
that's a weird system so a lens in a
contact yes the battery might be in the
glass and the glasses and it's working
and I don't know how it's connected but
hmm Wow well we this is who knows what
this is
here's the other thing I don't need the
information that fast that bad I'll okay
with the one-second delay if picking up
my phone and checking it instead of cuz
like what are you getting with you
thought I know the examples were like
incoming call the weather your emails
things like that like information you
can already get in two seconds by just
yep I have an incoming call I have an
email I have a text like that yeah
pretty quick pretty quick and I've I've
said this before where someone else
asking me like are we at like the final
form of smartphones like where are they
gonna go are we gonna get bigger okay
it's smaller are they gonna be implanted
in you I think smartphones are at like
pretty much their final form
we're gonna keep evolving the insides of
smartphones to be better they're gonna
get faster they're gonna get more and
more transparent whatever they'll get
like more interesting looking but I
think it's always gonna be a thing I
pick up and use and then put back down
mmm I think that's where we're at for a
while